heureusement soir le théâtre le roman
soirée théâtre nous sommes toujours sur
la terre en compagnie d'elie plenel
filippo de soan et nous accueillons
notre invité du samedi 20 heures ce soir
pierre rabhi bonsoir
alors qu'hier rabhi au début des années
60 vous arrivé d'algérie est plutôt que
de vous abrutir dans un travail à
l'usiné pour pouvoir goûter aux joies de
la modernité la télé le frigo la machine
à laver vous décidez de vous installer
en ardèche dans une ferme sans eau
courante sans électricité un demi siècle
plus tard vous êtes devenu mondialement
célèbre ou publier des livres vous
donner des conférences ou fait des films
vous êtes pierre aujourd'hui le pape de
la décroissance et un terrien extra vous
nous raconter votre histoire à 20 heures
[Musique]
pierre rabhi rebond soir vous êtes né le
29 mai 1938 à kenadsa une oasis
algérienne aux portes du sahara vers
votre père et est forgeron votre mère
est femme au foyer et votre maman meurt
quand vous avez quatre ans vous n'avez
même pas une photo d'elle c'est terrible
de ne pas avoir d' image
oui parce que nous avons besoin de nous
situer aux devoirs qu'elle est l'être
qui nous a mis au monde et qu'on a la
sensation d'être clandestins parce qu'on
n'a pas connu la l'être humain la
personne la femme qui vous a donné la
vie alors à la mort de votre mère votre
père en dos le rôle de maman auprès des
cinq enfants du couple il épouse une
autre femme et donc il reconstitue le
foyer mais on est dans une configuration
différente
alors votre père c'est un forgeron mais
il jouait du luth et jouer du violon il
écrivait des poèmes vous dit si une
divinité pour moi oui le souvenir que
j'en ai évidemment c'est c'est un être
d'exception alors au début des années 40
votre père est obligé de travailler dans
les mines de charbon
exploités par des entreprises françaises
tous les soirs il rentre à la maison
couvert de poussière noire et la du
noble forgeron vous ne voyez finalement
qu'un homme a servi par le par le
système est ce que c'est de là que naît
votre insoumission je pense que oui
parce que la notion d'aliénation entre
un homme libre forgeron qui fait chanter
l'enclume qu'il soir chante réjouit les
autres à nîmes et xetra et qui
finalement fini par devenir quelqu'un
qui rend tous les soirs soulier de
charbon
je pense que cette image du jour disons
que cette cette anecdote n'est pas
anodine dans les choix que je ferai plus
tard alors pour vous assurer un avenir
plus doux à l'âge de 6 ans votre père
vous confier à un couple de français il
veut que vous ayez le savoir des
européens pour vous préparer à affronter
le monde moderne c'est un incroyable
sacrifice de se séparer de son enfant
pour son bien mais c'est aussi une
preuve d'amour alors vous êtes donc
accueilli par ce couple de français
catholique sans enfant lui est ingénieur
elle est institutrice vous découvrez la
brosse à dents mais pas que ça et là
vous commencez à vous poser des
questions qui a raison est ce que c'est
la tradition est ce que c'est là la
modernité vous commencé très jeune à
vous intéresser aux philosophes parce
que ce sont ceux vers lequel on va pour
essayer d'avoir une réponse aux
questions fondamentales que nous avons
alors vous venez de fêter vos 15 ans
quand votre père adoptif et lutter à
oran ensuite à 750 km de chez vous vous
hésitez à partir évidemment à quitter
votre votre région mais là votre père
biologique tranche il vous dit vous y
allez mais il le faisait encore une fois
je n'ai jamais voulu parce qu'il le
faisait avec bien sûr bob pas dans une
intention d'amour et la nar adrien de
l'amour bien sont absolument et ça a été
du très difficile c'est dur on a vous
dit tout les amarres sont rompus à
partir de ce moment là seulement alors à
ce moment là vous commencez à vous
intéresser aux évangiles et vous est
bouleversée il ya de quoi évidemment par
le message d'amour de jésus-christ aimez
vous les uns les ont c'est une vibration
une puissance que chaque être humain en
lui et qui représente véritablement une
énergie là vous décidez de vous
convertir au christianisme
vous passez votre temps à cathédrale
d'oran oui vous êtes vraiment vous
servez la messe etc mais vous n'arrivez
pas en parler à votre famille quoi
c'était que je pouvait paraître un peu
comme quelqu'un qui aurait trahi voyant
que vous ne retournais plus haut village
votre père biologique décide de venir à
oran et là il vous découvre
impeccablement habillés avec des gants
beurre frais à la main parce qu'à
l'époque vont porter les gants à la main
vous allez au théâtre à l'opéra vous
arrêtez de la musique classique je suis
en train de devenir véritablement un
petit un petit occidental alors ce jour
là le père vous demande de rentrer
mais vous ne rentrez pas oui et je
prends une option définitive parce que
je ne pouvais pas être écartelée en l2
mais de culture c est la clé car
tellement on peut pas tenir longtemps
l'écartèlement vous restez vous ne
reverrez plus jamais votre père vous
n'irez pas à l'enterrement un non même
pas en 1958 en pleine guerre d'algérie
un jour vous êtes avec votre père
adoptif en train d'écouter à la radio
une allocution du maréchal juin et là
c'est pas trop pourquoi ça vous fait
remarquer à leur père adoptif que le
pari challes juin à une voix un peu
féminine et l'autre d'un gaulliste de la
première heure qui était menacé de mort
d'ailleurs à l'époque pour des raisons
politiques il réagi très violemment très
très violemment il vous dit demain je ne
veux plus te voir à la maison ils vous
vire réaction tout à fait rationnel mais
que j'ai compris parce que c'était qu'un
gaulliste effectivement
inconditionnel au milieu de deux du
monde de l' os etc sa voiture avait été
plastiqué ils étaient menacés de mort et
j'ai compris que ce qu'on appelle la
goutte qui fait déborder le vase ensuite
on entre dans un monde complètement
justement dans cette et rationalité
pierre est ce que vous lui avez pardonné
à tout à fait alors vous prenez un
paquebot pour la france devrait à paris
en 1959 vous devenez ouvriers
spécialisés à la someca et là alors vous
découvrez l'entreprise ou et la
hiérarchie les horaires fixes les
pointeuses c'est là où la fréquentation
des philosophes vous amène à vous
interroger finalement sur les
différentes conjonctures et moi ma
conclusion c'est est que l'homme était
aliéné par la modernité - et que donner
donner toute sa vie en échange d'un
salaire moi ça ne me convenait pas du
tout et je considérais que ma vie valait
plus qu'un salaire et quand on parle de
l'aliénation c'est à dire de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un itinéraire
d'incarcération de l'être humain et la
l'image que j'ai trouvé c'est à dire que
de dire écoutez il y as incarcération
puisque de la maternelle à l'université
on est enfermé dans un bahut ensuite
tout le monde travaille dans des boîtes
des grandes boîtes des petites boîtes et
cetera même pour pour s'amuser on va en
boîte on y va comment dans sa caisse et
puis à la boîte à vieux en attendant la
dernière boîte que vous devinez
voilà bon c'est quand même dans ces
entreprises que vous avez rencontré
l'amour en la personne de michel et
c'est là que en 1961 en pleine période
des trente glorieuses
vous décidez d'aller à contre-courant de
l'exode rural l'exode rural c'est jean
ferrat la montagne un bon voilà et vous
allez vous installer en ardèche avec
michel mais en 61 c'est à dire sept ans
avant les utopies de 68 qui on libérait
tout ça je vais retourner à la terre et
je vais me rapprocher des sources de la
vie c'était vers la nature et comment je
vais faire un bain je vais devenir
paysan voilà alors vous décidez de vous
installer en ardèche quand vous
découvrez l'agriculture
ardéchoise vous est effondrée par
l'utilisation des engrais vous dites on
est dans une guerre chimique contre la
nature et on était dans cette ambiance
dance de poison poison que l'on met dans
la terre avec les engrais chimiques
poisons que l'on répond sûr dans
l'environnement donc on n'était pas dans
une voie qui me convenait puisque je
n'étais pas venu pour déclarer la guerre
à la vie
voilà vous intéressez désormais à
l'agroécologie
c'est-à-dire traiter la terre avec
l'humus enfin en la préservant la
respecte et surtout et vous découvrez ce
que vous appelez la sobriété heureuse
qui est une espèce de morale pour vous
finalement au début vous êtes obligés de
faire plein de petits boulots
heureusement on fait des fromages ça
vous aide quand même beaucoup et puis
après 68 les idées changé beaucoup de
stagiaires comment ça vous découvrir à
venir du monde entier et la ferme
commence à un marché cet agrès écologie
faisait l'exporter en afrique au burkina
faso vous partez souvent vos enfants
regrette un peu de ne pas vous voir
enfin c'est pour la bonne cause mais
vous partez quand même voilà et en 2002
vos amis vous pousse à vous présenter
aux présidentielles
et là vous parler de décroissance une
civilisation dites-vous de la modération
et aujourd'hui on affirme tout le monde
affirme que l'agro écologie la seule
façon de doré de résoudre le problème de
la faim dans le monde nourrir tout le
monde bien sûr yoris à l'agroécologie
peut nourrir absolument tout le monde le
nord le suit partout partout l'écologie
prend en compte le fait que rien ne se
crée rien ne se perd tout se transforme
donc elle entretient la vie d'un côté on
a une agriculture qui produit est
détruit et ne peut pas produire sans
détruire et de l'autre côté vous avez
l'agroécologie qui produisent non
seulement sans détruire mais régénère
comme je lé fais au sahel avec des sols
difficiles et rapide la terre finalement
c'est à dire chaque fois qu'un paysan et
formés à cela et bien il participe à la
régénération des sols à la régénération
d'environnement alors avant de se
quitter j'oserais dire vous êtes aussi à
l'origine du mouvement des colibris et
les jo et que nous racontions l'histoire
des colibris
aujourd'hui vous savez très bien qu'on
est dans une espèce de marasme dans les
incertitude totale par rapport au futur
est dans cette situation là aussi dit
alors très souvent on dit bah c'est
l'état c'est le si la politique c'est je
sais par quoi qu'irresponsable boxer en
permanence et j'ai eu la chance donc de
tomber sur un petit conte amérindiens
qui dit qu'un jour il ya eu un grand
incendie de forêt tous les animaux
étaient atterrés
décourager et c est le petit colibri ce
petit oiseau tout gracile tout presque
insignifiant mais très beau lui il va
prendre quelques gouttes d'eau dans son
bec il les jette sur le feu et ils
s'activent le tattoo qui est la leur
garde depuis un bon moment et rudy
colibri une image quand même pas que
c'est avec ça que tu va éteindre le feu
il regarde en face et lui dit je le sais
mais je fais ma part voilà je fais ma
part passera le mot de la fin
je rappelle le titre du dernier livre
qui vous est consacré pierre rabhi
semeur d'espoir entretien avec olivier
l'honneur chez actes sud merci d'abord
été avec nous ça nous fait du bien
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater le il a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu